je vous remercie monsieur le monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre samedi se
tenait en savoir une conférence de
presse destinée à présenter la tribune
cossignée par élus syndicalisme
représentant des associations et les
locaux et parlementaire nous étions plus
de 200 de toutes sensibilité politique
confondues nous souhaitions rappeler nos
engagements pour le chantier ferroviaire
du lion Turin et notre choix du scénario
grand gabarit pour ses accès à la suite
de la consultation que vous avez menée
le gouvernement devait prendre une
position officielle en début d'année ce
n'est toujours pas fait je vous rappelle
mes courriers restez sans réponse de
plus en l'absence de décision vous
ouvrez une brèche à une minorité
d'activistes qui se disent écologiste
mais sont contradictoires dans leur
discours ils cherchent à effrayer nos
populations par la désinformation en
s'appuyant depuis plus de 30 ans sur les
thèmes à la mode du moment roche
radioactive roche amiantifère et
aujourd'hui avec les sécheresses il
pointe les atteintes aux sources d'eau
pourtant l'entreprise binationale telle
te suit de façon très sérieuse ce sujet
en lien avec les élus locaux c'est par
le faitoutage que nous réussirons à
diminuer nos émissions carbonées et à
améliorer la qualité de l'air dans nos
valises la ligne historique n'en a pas
la capacité et nous devons en parallèle
libérer des sillons pour les transports
voyageurs du quotidien la légitimité
démocratique à faire des choix qui
engagent l'avenir de nos enfants
appartient bien aux élus et non à une
poignée de militants opposés au projet
monsieur le ministre ne vous laissez pas
impressionner prenez les décisions
attendues la question n'est plus d'être
pour ou contre ce tunnel il s'agit d'un
déterminer ses accès et d'en assurer
leur financement aussi mes questions
sont simples quand comptez-vous
confirmer officiellement le scénario
retenu
d'autre part l'Union européenne a
annoncé 50% de financement pour les
accès vous n'avez pas postulé à son
appel à projet opération ferroviaire
alors que le percement du tunnel est en
cours quand le